The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: This is going
to be really informal
and you can try and
follow along if you want.
I'm just going to show you my
basic workflow from Illustrator
to After Effects to
Premiere and some important,
I guess basic tools
that you might use.
This is Elizabeth.
OK.
I just started.
We finally got
everything set up.
I don't know how to
make it any better.
OK.
So first thing is
creating your new canvas.
So if you open up Illustrator,
it's just File New.
You can name it
whatever you want.
And then the profile is
going to be automatically set
to one of the options, but I
adjust the width and the height
to match the screen size of
the video that we capture.
Which is usually
1920 by 1080 pixels.
So you want to make
sure the width is 1920,
the height is 1080, and
the units are pixels.
And you can keep the color mode
and the pixel grid the same.
And you press OK.
And your screen should
look something like this.
And this is just
the drawing surface
on which you're going to work.
Do you guys want to
follow along or should I
just keep going from here?
Nod.
AUDIENCE: How about-- sorry,
can you go through just
like drawing a single shape.
And then maybe draw
a person's face
and then export it
out of Illustrator
and then animate it in After
Effects and save the movie?
PROFESSOR: That's
what-- yeah, OK.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Oh, is that
what you're going to do?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Sorry.
Go ahead.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
No worries.
So this is just going
over some basic tools.
I like expanding
the right tool panel
just so I can see everything,
especially the layers.
That's a tool I use a lot.
Basic tools that you're going
to use are the paint brush.
This is how you mimic
writing on your tablet
so you can mimic
your handwriting.
You can draw basic shapes with
this, but they appear as lines.
So everything in
Illustrator is a vector.
So this is a solid object.
And then if you
want to make shapes,
there's a rectangle
tool over here
and you can hold down on
it and find other shapes.
And then you can just
drag to place it.
If you want to change
the border color,
or the color of an individual
line, you can click on this.
This is stroke color.
Double click and it'll just
give you a full-color spectrum.
You can select anything.
And if you want to change
the fill-- right now,
the fill, the white box
with the red line through it
means that it's transparent.
But you can choose any color
you want and change the shape.
If you want to draw
a free-form shape,
the pencil tool will
connect lines to make
a potentially solid object.
So if you want to
make an irregular
polygon or some other shape,
the pencil tool automatically
connects them even if you don't
completely draw them together.
You can also redraw
lines sometimes
if you draw them in
the same direction
that you originally did.
So you can adjust the
border of a shape slightly.
What else?
The black selection tool can
help you select entire objects.
You highlight--
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
PROFESSOR: No.
No worries.
Is it not recording?
AUDIENCE: No, it was not.
PROFESSOR: Do you want me to
do a Quicktime recording just
as backup?
AUDIENCE: Yes, as a backup.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So the black selection arrow can
help you select entire objects
or you can drag to
select groups of objects.
The white selection arrow, you
can select individual points
on objects.
So you can select a point on the
path and then move it around.
So you can warp a line
that already exists.
And change its direction
and things like that.
The eyedropper tool
is useful if you--
let's say I took a paint brush
and I had a specific stroke
weight.
I had a specific
color that I was using
to draw a circle or a spiral.
And then I reverted back
to black at one point,
but I want to go back
to that size and color.
The eyedropper tool will
hold both those informations.
So if I just eyedropper
that, then it
will turn blue and
in 8-point brush.
But if I eye-drop the block,
then it'll go back to 1-point
in black.
So it just saves
you some time if you
want to completely
recreate something.
The last thing that's important
in Illustrator is layers.
I usually divide up my project
based on types of objects.
So if I was doing
this from scratch,
I would probably
put all the stuff
I drew with a paint brush on
one layer and all the shapes
on a separate layer.
You create a new layer just by
clicking this new little page
here.
And it's basically just
a way to group objects
and manipulate them
independently from each other.
So, for example, I will move
this square into layer one.
And I'll those animate
using layer two.
And you can toggle a
lock on each layer.
So if I put a lock
on layer one, that
means I can't do anything
to these objects,
like I can't manipulate
them accidentally.
And the eyeball triggers
whether you can see it or not.
So sometimes you want to
draw something in one layer
and then you create a
couple more on top of it,
and you don't want to
see the original one.
And I usually name
my layers something
to remind me what they are for
the purposes of After Effects.
Just so it's less
confusing when I get there.
So this would be text.
And layer two will be rectangle.
That's pretty much all there
is to know about Illustrator.
You can save the files.
It'll save as a .ai, which
is important when you animate
something.
Save it somewhere where you're
going to remember where it is.
And you can just keep
the default settings.
So here's where it's
going to branch off
if you want a still transparent
image over your video
or an animation.
If you just want a
still transparent image,
you can draw it in
Illustrator like this.
Just click File, Export.
And it'll automatically
go to PNG.
Click Use Artboards because that
preserves the screen dimensions
that you specified
in the beginning.
And you click Export.
And it'll give you
this pop up window
and here is where you
can choose whether you
want a white background, a black
background, or a transparent.
Which is really nice if you
just want a text overlay
on your video because
you automatically
have an image with vector
art in it, or vector words,
and a transparent background.
And you can just click
OK, and then your image
will be exported.
I think mine's in
my downloads folder.
Yeah.
Just as a PNG file, which
you can import into iMovie
or Premiere or Final Cut Pro.
And overlay it just like
another video track or an image.
That is everything
for Illustrator.
So I will close that.
Now, if you want
to animate, animate
in After Effects most likely.
You can also learn
Flash animation,
but that's a different
concept behind it.
So the way to start a
composition in After Effects
and import your images that
you started in Illustrator.
You exit out of
the initial window
when it asks you to create a
new composition because we're
going to just import our
files from Illustrator
as a new composition.
So you just double click
in the project window
and it'll give you a pop-up
window that says Import File.
I'm sure there's
another way to do this,
but this is just
how I was taught.
You can probably go File
Open or something like that.
Go to wherever you saved
your Illustrator file,
enable all acceptable
files, and then import it
as a composition.
That just means it will process
each layer in your Illustrator
file as a different layer
in your composition, which
will be important when
it comes to animating.
And then from here, you
can alter your Composition
Settings.
And you can name
your composition.
It will automatically
adopt the name
that you named your
Illustrator file.
You can customize the
width and the height,
which should be the same
dimensions that you specified
before.
You want it to be
in square pixels.
Sometimes it defaults
to a different size,
and I think rectangular
pixels are silly
and they mess up how
your video's going
to look eventually.
Or how your animations
relate to your video.
The frame rate is
important because it
allows you to match up
your animation exactly
to your video.
In Adobe Premiere
the frame rate is 30.
The default for
After Effects is 25.
And that messed me up
on my first project
because I was trying
to time everything
and then it was off by
five frames per second,
which is really frustrating.
I don't know what they are
for iMovie or Final Cut,
but I would check when you go in
before you start your project.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
I set the background
color to white
just so I can see
everything because I usually
draw with a white
background in Illustrator.
If you want to set the default
background in Illustrator
to black and do
white text, and set
that as transparent in
front of your video,
then a black background
would make more sense.
This background color does
not export with the video,
though, so your animations
are still transparent.
It's just so you can see
things in After Effects.
And usually what I do before I
start an After Effects project
is I look at how long the
audio is for the portion
that I want to animate.
So for example, I was
working with Andrea yesterday
and she wanted a goat during
one of her lines when she says,
and the force of a mountain
goat jumping on your teeth
is some amount of newtons.
Or whatever a line is.
And you look at the
duration of how long
it takes you to say that line
in your editing software.
And that's how long I set my
duration of my animation to be.
Just so it's really easy.
It's really modular.
I'm animating for
this part of the video
and I have this much
space to do it in.
And because I don't have
an audio track right now,
I'm just going to
set it to 15 seconds.
So that's good.
Then you can double click on
your composition to open it.
And this is going to
be your display window.
This is your timeline.
It's where I guess the
animation is taking place
and you can see
different things.
And here is where
you're going to be doing
a lot of the animation stuff.
This little Options
window, I guess.
You can still toggle
the visibility
just like you did
in Illustrator.
And so let's say-- I'm going
to show you how to animate
this rectangle, for example.
So the first thing you want
to do is right click on it
and Create Shapes
from the vector layer.
Basically this just
allows After Effects
to take the vector shapes,
or objects that you created
in Illustrator, and translate
it into a manipulable format
for After Effects.
So then you have this new
item-- object-- I don't know,
called Rectangle Outlines.
And you can look inside
in their contents.
If you had multiple
objects in the same layer,
you'd have multiple
groups, but I just
have the one rectangle
so I only have group one.
And so in order to move
this, what I'm going to do
is open up group one.
And I have different options.
And you guys are
going to be doing
a lot of Transform animations.
So these are things like if you
want something to move around
on the screen, if you want
something to change in size
or rotate, or things like that.
So what you're going to
do for if you wanted--
let's say I wanted
this rectangle
to move across the
screen and grow bigger.
The things that I will--
and in After Effects you
want to think in key frames.
So what does it look like at
one point in the animation,
and then what do you want it
to look like in two seconds?
So right now this is
where I want it to start.
So I'll click a little
stopwatch on position and scale,
and these will set key frames
for both position and scale.
So now After Effects
remembers where the rectangle
is at this point in time.
Then I'll set it forward
to let's say two seconds.
In two seconds I want
my rectangle to move.
And then it's as easy as
dragging the rectangle
to where you want it to be
and then changing its size.
So let's say I want it to
be really big like that.
And then once you make
those changes, After Effects
automatically sets another key
frame for you in your timeline.
And then you can review what
you want the animation to do
by dragging this back
and pushing Space, which
is the same thing as Play.
And then you can watch
how over the two seconds,
it transitions from one point in
space to another point in space
and one size to another size.
You can edit and
delete key frames.
You can add more in the middle.
Let's say I wanted it to
go up and left before I
wanted it to go up and right.
You can just set it to the
middle of this animation
and drag it up and left to
where you would want it to be.
And then it'll keep scaling
the size at the same time,
but then it will just
adjust its position path
in the new animation.
And that's the bare
bones of animation.
The one other thing you guys
might use is-- let's see.
If you want to
group multiple items
and have them move
at the same time,
for example-- I'm going
to take my text layer,
Create Shapes from
Vector Layer, and now I
have another layer of objects.
Except this one
has many contents.
Many groups of things
that I can manipulate.
So let's say I want both
these spirals to move
at the same time.
I haven't found a
better way to do this,
but-- so I learned that
the spirals are groups
two and three.
I can click on Contents just
to highlight everything,
Add a New Empty
Group, and it's just
labeled whatever the highest
number-- one after the highest
number.
You can rename it to
something like Spirals
so you remember it.
You can highlight
both of these and just
drag it into the new group.
And that way you can
transform spirals as a unit.
Let's say I wanted
them to rotate.
And so then-- OK.
That's kind of rotating.
And so it set the key
frames for rotations,
but instead of just
manipulating one spiral
I have two grouped together.
And then the rectangle animation
is still going from before.
AUDIENCE: Can you [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: What do you mean?
AUDIENCE: With the
point they pivot on?
PROFESSOR: Pivot point?
I think so.
I don't usually rotate
things in my animations.
I think it's probably
the anchor point.
AUDIENCE: See the cross-hair?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So that's the pivot point.
I don't know how to
change that necessarily.
OK.
There you go.
You can just adjust it in
relation to the anchor point.
So you can change this value.
Yeah.
A lot of this is
just playing around
and seeing what you want to do.
You can ask me
questions afterward
and I'd be happy to
troubleshoot it with you.
Yeah.
So I guess that's how you pivot.
And so it'll maintain
the rotation just
around the smaller
anchor point now.
Let's see.
This is might be useful.
So if you go in and you have a
lot of work-- so for example,
in a different project
what happened was
I had the outline of a
cell and I was showing
contents of the nucleus.
And when I screened it
to my project advisor,
she said it's great
but we're not focusing
on the nucleus of the cell.
And so I can't really
see what's going on.
So I had already done
all this animation
with individual squiggles
of DNA and proteins
moving around in
the nucleus, and I
wanted to preserve
that animation,
but I needed to just
zoom in on everything.
And you can do this with a
thing called Null Object.
Let's see if I remember
how to do this.
OK.
Layer New and then
a Null Object.
And so it'll appear in
here as just Null One.
And basically it's a way to
group multiple animations
at the same time.
You can just leave that
named Null One I guess.
So let's say I want the
spiral and the rectangle
to both be smaller because
they're both way too big.
So then you can you
can set the Null Object
as the parent of these layers.
It says Parent and you
can have a drop-down menu.
And so you can set both these
layers to have their parent
as Null One, and then you can
animate Null one as though it
were an independent object.
So let's say I just want the
scale of everything to go down.
So because those are both groups
that are under the Null Layer,
then the scale goes down.
Or you can animate
it independently.
So let's say I want
the scale at 100%,
but as the rectangle grows
I want everything to shrink
because it got too big.
So then you can turn the
scale down of everything.
And so when I run the animation,
the rectangle is going to grow,
the spirals are going to
rotate, but then everything,
because it's all grouped
under the Null Layer,
is going to shrink.
And so I guess those
are the basics of it.
Once you have your
After Effects file,
I would save it
as something just
so you don't lose anything.
And then you can do
one of two things.
So if you want to
edit in Premiere,
you can start-- Adobe
products are really nice where
they auto-update to each other.
So if you change the
Illustrator files that make up
the composition
in After Effects,
then your After
Effects will change
to reflect those changes.
So if you messed up
drawing something,
or you want a shape to look
a little bit different,
if you update the Illustrator
file your After Effects project
will also update.
Same thing with your After
Effects Project and Premiere.
So if I have a
Premiere project, you
can drag your After Effects
composition into Premiere
just to import media.
And then I have
my test animation
and I can drop it here
to create a sequence.
And so right now,
because it's transparent,
I can't see anything.
But if I were to add a
color match in light blue--
this is going to
be really garish--
and add it on the video
layer below the animation,
then it will appear.
So the animation
itself is transparent.
And so now if I make
changes in After Effects,
it'll automatically
update those changes
in Premiere, which I
find really handy as I'm
video editing and
switching back and forth.
If you don't want to edit in
Premiere, that is totally fine,
and you just need to
export your composition.
I was just playing
around with this earlier.
Usually I don't export,
so I don't necessarily
have the ideal settings
for it, but we can
play around and see what works.
So File Export to
Adobe Media Encoder.
And then it adds it
automatically to the queue.
And you can choose preset
export settings over here.
I created a preset for the
videos that I'm working on
and so I usually
just select that.
And then once you do all that,
then you can just push play.
And then the media
encoder does its thing.
I don't know exactly
what it does.
I think it's a combination
of rendering and just making
sure-- changing the file format
from the After Effects Project
to, in this case, an MP4 file.
AUDIENCE: So, for
a lot of yours,
I'm imagining you want to
do Animation Overlay, right?
So you can't do that
in stuff like iMovie,
so what you will
have to do, which
is a super techy workaround,
is you create the animation
in After Effects,
you go in Premier
and that's where you overlay
it on top of your live action
footage, and then you export
that little chunk into your Add
Movie Project.
Does that make
sense to you guys?
So would you mind showing real
quick how to do it in Premiere
where you overlay an animation
on top of your live action
footage?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
So it's basically
just doing what
I was doing and just using
something besides the color
mat.
I will see if I have any
movies on my computer.
I don't know if I do.
AUDIENCE: So if you are holding
your hands out like this,
what's the best way to time
and place the animations?
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: Because
you basically have
to draw them without
seeing a background
in After Effects, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
OK.
I have a video.
So the way I would
animate in After Effects
is to use the time codes.
So Premiere has a time
code, and it's right here,
and it matches up with
where the movie is.
So right now the animation
is overlaid for my movie,
and the formatting
is weird because I
didn't do the movie first.
What I would do is,
let's say for example
I wanted at five
seconds something
to happen, like something
to pop up above my hand,
then I would take
note of the time code
or whenever you raise
your hand in the video.
So let's say it was at
11 seconds and 24 frames.
Then you go back into
Adobe After Effects
and you can scroll
over to 11 frames
and make sure the time
code here is listed here.
And so you just
switch back and forth
and adjust the time code of
your animations to the time code
where you want it to
appear in the video.
And you can drag key
frames to adjust that.
So if I say, well the rectangle
moved too fast in this video,
I actually want the
animation to end
at 3:29 instead of two seconds,
I can drag my cursor to 3:29,
and then just drag the
key frame to match it.
That's usually how I
do it just because it's
a lot easier to visualize.
And then it will
automatically update in here
and the animation
just got a lot longer.
And so now when I push play,
instead of taking two seconds
it's still going until 3:29.
It's a lot of playing around.
I don't have a really, really
concrete method of doing it.
And I'm still learning
animation too,
so I don't have
the perfect answer,
but usually it's a lot of
switching between windows,
which is why when you have
two monitors it's really nice.
But a lot of just checking the
time code exactly and making
little adjustments at a time.
It's kind of like
how you edit a movie.
You start with a rough cut.
You start with a rough
animation of what you want,
and then you can adjust the key
frames to time it to the video
that you're working with.
AUDIENCE: So I think what will
be most productive for you
guys is if you attempt
to do your own animation
and then if you run into any
problems, email [INAUDIBLE],
or you can email me.
We'll be around tomorrow
if people are working,
and I'll be on campus tomorrow
actually if you need help.
But I think the
most efficient route
is if you try a little
bit on your own first
and then when specific questions
pop up you can come ask us.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And if you have anything
specific in mind
that you don't think you can
accomplish with what I've
taught you so far, then you
can definitely come talk to me
or I can come over
and talk to you.
And we can talk through
what your picture was
for animating something
and how you can best
do that either using the
tools that I just taught you
or using other things.
Like I know how to
mimic handwriting
to write out a word.
And I don't know if that's
necessary for any of you,
but that's a thing that you
can do in After Effects.
It's just a little
more complicated
than what I've shown you so far.
AUDIENCE: I have two questions.
One of them is I have used
Adobe Premiere before,
but in the sizing, of
course I'm not sure
when I'm doing
[INAUDIBLE] it looks
like the sizing is correct.
However, when I export
it into external video,
the sizing was wrong.
So is this a thing?
PROFESSOR: For
exporting from Premiere?
AUDIENCE: I mean like, if
I see the screen like this,
is this everything that's
on the screen that will
be shown in the actually video?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So what this is-- I recorded
this movie on my camera
on my computer, which
is lower quality
than your camcorders, which
should record in 1920 by 1080.
So right now, this in the
upper right hand corner
is what's going to be exported.
So if I exported
it right now, it
would export with this
weird black border
because my video is smaller
than this composition.
AUDIENCE: So it's preferable
to expand the screen?
Can we expand the video?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you
can individually--
you can double click, and this
is how you digitally zoom.
Basically.
You can manipulate it
just like any other object
and make it bigger so
it fills the screen.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What do you mean?
AUDIENCE: So this [INAUDIBLE]
would be the one that--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So whatever you see
in this preview screen
is what's going to come
out when you export it.
And then you can
change export settings.
File Export Media.
And you can change the file
type that you want it to be
and the video format.
I use the settings that
MITx needs to upload usually
just because it works and it
produces a high enough quality
video.
But if you know things
about audio and video
and things like
that, you can add
a copyright encoded
into the video itself
if you really want to protect
it and things like that.
But less necessary.
AUDIENCE: If you're going to
check the camera we're given,
it's how many frames per second?
AUDIENCE: I think it's 30.
I'll double-check it.
AUDIENCE: And if I want to get
a-- let's say I have video.
I took a video.
But at the moment I
want to cut that frame
and extend that frame to
make it like a picture.
[INAUDIBLE] explain the concept.
So how do I do that?
PROFESSOR: So this
is something--
I don't know how to
do it in Final Cut.
I know how to do it in Premiere.
So hypothetically in Premiere--
that's a bad frame pause.
Let's say I want to
pause this frame,
there's a button here that
just says Export Frame.
I click it and then
what do I want it to be?
Still Face.
I just wanted a JPEG, I guess.
And then this box just
means that you import it
into the project automatically.
So no matter where it
saves it-- in this case
it's saving it in my Premiere
folder-- you click OK
and then it automatically
appears as an image
in your media browser area.
And so then if
you want to extend
this frame, what I
would personally do
is use the Razor tool.
Cut the clip into two.
Use the Selection tool and drag
this over so I have some space
to include it.
And then include
the still image.
And then just seal
that gap back up.
So now, instead of just seeing
me talk, I'll talk, I'll talk,
I'll talk, and then the still
frame will happen for however
many seconds you set it, and you
can adjust the size and timing
of that, and then the
video will resume when
you're ready for it to do that.
AUDIENCE: I don't
exactly know what
the frame rate of
the [INAUDIBLE]
is because it records
both in 24 and 30,
but if you open the
video up in Quicktime
and you do Command I, which
is what it was recorded in.
And I just found that
out by Googling it,
so don't underestimate
the power of Google.
PROFESSOR: Are there
any other questions
about animating or
editing or Adobe?
PROFESSOR: I mean,
we're just going
to stick around for
the rest of today
so if you just want to hang
out here and work or you want
to go back to the
classroom and work,
we'll be around to
answer your questions.